[Música]
y hablamos de la crisis de seguridad que
se registra en ecuador y que afecta
principalmente a la ciudad de guayaquil
la capital económica del país es
considerada así el presidente guillermo
lasso asumió la coordinación nacional de
las fuerzas del orden para así enfrentar
a las mafias delincuenciales que
principalmente se disputan el tráfico de
drogas y que mantienen en alerta al país
por los altos índices de violencia como
medida la son renovó por 30 días
adicionales el estado de excepción que
él había decretado el pasado 18 de
octubre a raíz de esta grave crisis de
seguridad en las calles y en las
prisiones para ello quiero saludar
entonces a mario pazmiño el ex consultor
internacional en seguridad y defensa ex
director de inteligencia de ecuador
mario gracias por estar con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 le pregunta
entonces el origen de esta crisis de
seguridad en el ecuador
existen muy buenos días existe una
improvisación gubernamental que está
articulado con tres potenciadores estos
tres potenciadores son la presencia de
dos cárteles internacionales mexicanos
aproximadamente unas 12 mega bandas que
operan internamente en el país y
altísimos niveles de corrupción esto han
permeado todo lo que es el sistema
carcelario y han colocado en una
posición de inseguridad permanente no
sólo el sistema carcelario sino todo al
todo el sistema de seguridad federal del
estado ahora mario lo que ocurre dentro
de las cárceles con estos motines que
hemos visto recientemente que han dejado
decenas de muertos se pueden ver como
una radiografía de lo que pasa en las
calles del país
es correcto gran parte de la inseguridad
que se genera en los cientos carcelarios
de ha sido una metástasis que se ha
proyectado hacia los centros urbanos
especialmente donde se encuentran los
centros de acopio y las plataformas
internacionales de distribución de
narcóticos recordemos rápidamente que el
37.5 por ciento de la droga la cocaína
que ingresa desde colombia pues sale por
los puertos ecuatorianos especialmente
el puerto de guayaquil la provincia de
manabí puerto de manta en conexión hacia
alta mar para comenzar a comprometer las
cargas que vienen en los transportes los
sales de los transportes de riesgos
ahora mario pues le quiero preguntar
ahora específicamente en la ciudad de
guayaquil porque se volvió entonces es
tan violenta es un territorio de disputa
y también de dónde sale la droga desde
ecuador desde la ciudad de guayaquil
sí correcto web él está en uno de los
corredores importantes del narcotráfico
y especialmente es el corredor de la
zona 8 que va a desembocar en el puerto
de web y por donde sales del 52% de
cocaína y existen dos cárteles que están
operando la cártel de sinaloa el cártel
calixto nueva generación paralelamente a
eso estas disputas territoriales también
se han incrementado por el microtráfico
que existe en la zona y esto genera a su
vez inseguridad y ajuste de cuentas y
una gran la actividad de sicariato es lo
que ha incrementado sustancialmente el
nivel de muertes en esa región ahora el
presidente guillermo lasso extendió este
estado decepción en las calles para
aumentar la seguridad que tanto ha
funcionado que la policía y también los
militares estén en las calles realmente
se ha disminuido la violencia en las
calles de ecuador y sobre todo en la
ciudad de guayaquil como lo estábamos
hablando
no yo creo que no el estado de excepción
son medidas parches que está tomando el
gobierno para decir a la población que
están haciendo algo en sí pero no se
está atacando frontalmente la amenaza
estructural al estado ecuatoriano pones
la amenaza estructural amenaza
estructural es el crimen organizado
transnacional en el que el narcotráfico
estamos atacando una parte un apéndice
de esta gran estructura delictiva es la
delincuencia común y los niveles de
violencia que genera ahora misma pero no
estamos atacando potencialmente toda la
estructura delictiva y eso es lo que
debería hacer el estado una medida
concreta o varias o cuáles son las
medidas concretas a su opinión que
debería implementar implementar el
estado ecuatoriano para lograr
estabilizar un poco la seguridad del
país
lo primero creo yo que hay que
restablecer la fuerza de tarea conjunta
esmeralda es que estaba dando excelentes
resultados especialmente taponando todo
lo que es el ingreso de drogas desde
colombia hacia territorio ecuatoriano la
segunda la conformación de una fuerza de
tarea conjunta del litoral ecuatoriano
porque el tema de la amenaza de cambio
ya de escenario no puede ser catalogada
una amenaza el crimen organizado
transnacional como una amenaza a la
seguridad ciudadana tiene que ser
catalogado al momento como una amenaza a
la seguridad nacional por lo tanto esta
fuerza de tarea conjunta del litoral
puede restablecer los niveles de
seguridad en toda la costa ecuatoriana
tercero creo que es importantísimo la
militarización de puertos y aeropuertos
en virtud de que existe al momento gran
salida de cocaína y de otros recursos
también por los puertos de aeropuertos
ecuatorianos hay que combatirlo esto y
la mejor forma de hacerlo es más una
militarización de estos puertos 10 de
impuestos hasta que las condiciones de
mejor por otro lado las unidades
especiales que tiene el ejército y la
policía nacional tiene patrullas
específicamente por los lugares de
acceso de este estupefaciente que son
los ríos los afluentes que van a
desembocar en el pacífico gran parte de
ellos son utilizados por las diferentes
organizaciones del narcotráfico para
trasladar la droga hacia el territorio
ecuatoriano y también por las diferentes
truchas en la frontera con ahora como la
pobreza y la desigualdad que vivimos en
nuestros países latinoamericanos y
específicamente trasladado entonces a
este caso de ecuador como esto
incrementa la violencia y la seguridad y
como estas organizaciones criminales de
narcotráfico se aprovechan de las
personas más vulnerables para poder pues
trabajar con ellos no básicamente pues
el gran potencial económico que tienen
las diferentes organizaciones delictivas
pues generan un reclutamiento permanente
por poner un ejemplo rápido en la
frontera norte con colómbia gran parte
de la población que esté la frontera son
utilizados de raspachines de la persona
que barras para roca de boca y reciben
un sueldo diario de cerca de 30 y 35
dólares
este este sueldo sirvan con más miembros
de la familia se puede triplicar
cuatriplicar y esto genera un ingreso
sumamente sustancial entonces las
personas que no tienen otra forma de
trabajo pues se ven atraídas hacia este
tipo de acciones por eso es que es
importante que el estado tenga una
presencia mucho más fuerte generando
procesos de seguridad y desarrollo en la
frontera al norte para los dos países
tanto colombia para la ecuador
ahora también mario el presidente de
colombiano iván duque se reunió con su
homólogo de ecuatoriano guillermo lazo
para tratar temas de seguridad entre
otras cosas también el narcotráfico e
iván duque se comprometió a ayudar a
ecuador para tratar de erradicar el
narcotráfico o puedes mermar lo un poco
como un país con colombia también con un
índice alto de narcotráfico que todavía
no ha controlado pueda ayudar a otro
país también con este tema de
narcotráfico como lo es ecuador además
cuando la droga sale desde colombia
hacia el territorio ecuatoriano
y lo veo sumamente difícil en el
ofrecimiento del presidente iván duque
tomemos en consideración que en el
tiempo del presidente uribe te dio el
efecto globo y las repercusiones fueron
gravísimas para el ecuador el ecuador en
un país de tránsito hasta
1990 hasta el 2003 aproximadamente a
partir del 2004 comienza un cambio de
estatus en el país ese cambio de estatus
se da porque gran parte de la maquinaria
del narcotráfico comienza a pasar a
traspasar la frontera y se instala en
territorio ecuatoriano no la parte del
cultivo pero si la parte del
procesamiento de el acopio y también la
salida de este producto si el exterior
al momento dimos un salto mucho más
grande y el salto mucho más grande es
que admob somos considerados por la
administración bayern como un país que
está dedicado al procesamiento de
cocaína así somos conocidos y conocidos
internacionalmente y estamos ya en la
lista de los países en este tipo de
situación delictivas